commune du tampon dans le sud de l'île
comme plusieurs fois par semaine pour
l'eau seront en marché couvert du centre
ville pour acheter ce jour là des brain
ma fan il prépare un rom hasard le
romazava prononcer roma zave est un mets
traditionnel de la cuisine malgache à
base de viande et de break dont
notamment des brain ma fan
c'est en tout cas comme ceux-là qui
définit le plat sur les encyclopédies en
ligne
mais la définition de polo est un peu
différente arrivé chez lui en triant ses
brèves avec stéphanie sa compagne
il nous explique en fait l'euro malade
il est en deux mots il ya le mot groupe
qui veut dire bouillon et mazars qui
veut dire claire et avec le temps il
n'est plus si clair que ça a aidé plus
fourni en fait moi personnellement je
mets du boeuf mais il y en a qui le font
au poulet au port
c'est comme on veut et puis des brèdes
aussi on fait avec ce qu'il a apporté en
général donc
les brainois fans un peu de brett
chinois un peu de cresson que deux on
fait ce qu'on veut en fait vous vous
rappelez de feydeau en bis qui a eu pas
mal de succès à la réunion il a une
chanson qui dit au voisin à berlin dans
à la commande en syrie en fait ça veut
dire le roux mazars avec beaucoup d'eau
je ne l'aiment pas trop parce qu'il faut
beaucoup de sang
ah l'amour
sunu
a madagascar le romazava désigne donc un
bouillon clair avec un principal
ingrédient des brèdes quel qu'il soit
cuisiner avec des oignons de l'ail et du
gingembre pour les familles les plus
aisées on y rajoute de la viande mais à
la réunion le pl a évolué comme nous
l'expliquent lolo un ami venu rendre
visite
apollo et stéphanie là on a justement
nos romazava amélioré en fait à la
réunion ce que j'ai jeune j'avais
compris c'est ça quand il ya des brèdes
dumas fans donc il faut il faut qu'il
prenne ma faim hamada s'était pas obligé
pas obligés du tout d'euros mazars ça
peut être des brèdes mourront seulement
des feux de près d'une route sans viande
ni rien avec avec carrément une marmite
d'eau quoi aussi le bread patates douces
on imagine facilement que le premier aux
mazades cuisiner sur lille l'a été avec
des brèdes ma fan et du boeuf
ces 2 ingrédients sont devenus les
principaux du romazava version
réunionnaise mais sur la grande île le
rom asaf qui est un accompagnement
devient le plat principal pour beaucoup
de familles bien beaucoup de familles
malgaches on peut le dire ne sont pas
n'ont pas les moyens
du coup on se prive du plat principal du
cari d'une loque
on a dit et on passe directement rhji
rumasa j'ai assisté à des repas ou dans
le rouge madame d'un d'une marmite comme
ça il doit y avoir trois ou quatre
morceaux de viande et 1 grâce pour
donner juste le goût ce qui en tout cas
sûr c'est que ce plat de base malgache
et devenu un mets très apprécié sur
l'île et même servi ailleurs dans de
grands restaurants
ce qui rend les malgaches pas peu fier
en est chauvin kormann
l'humble à malgache ils viennent
s'intégrer à la société réunionnaise qui
dans la filière à quelques origines
malgaches aussi les grands restaurants
genre quatre écoles 5 étoiles hamadan
hester je vous parle pour ne pas citer
carlton par exemple où les d'autres
grand grand grand restaurant on propose
de roumanoff mais améliorée maintenant
c'est à dire à la façon des rôles
voilà donc comment un pas d'ailleurs est
venue enrichir la culture réunionnaise
une culture faite de métissage est en
constante évolution